bad acting worse writing and directors
put on blast some movies are so bad even
their Stars hate being in them though it
suffered from bad reviews upon its
initial release the sound of music has
gone on to become one of the most
beloved movie musicals of all time
families regularly gather around their
televisions to watch it the songs remain
catchy and Julie Andrews performance as
Maria is an iconic piece of work matched
only by her role as Mary Poppins that
said one of the film's other stars has
never been a fan Christopher Plummer has
spent decades reminding viewers that he
never liked the sound of music referring
to the film as the sound of mucus s m or
simply that movie at various points over
the years in 2010 he told the Boston
Globe I was a bit bored with the
character although we worked hard enough
to make him interesting it was a bit
like flogging a dead horse and the
subject matter is not mine I mean it
can't appeal to every person in the
world it's not my cup of tea before his
death in 2021 Plummer always made his
thoughts on the film clear albeit while
also acknowledging that people
everywhere love it in a 2015 interview
with Vanity Fair he said as cynical as I
always was about the sound of music I do
respect that it is a bit of relief from
all the gunfire and car chases you see
these days it's sort of wonderfully
old-fashionedly Universal
by the time the film that would be
released as Star Wars came into his life
cirella Guinness was already a legend
and that's why director George Lucas
wanted him the young filmmaker hoped the
name and reputation of the star would
bolster his film which largely starred
unknowns and offered sir Alec a chunk of
the film's earnings in exchange Guinness
thinking it was just another payday took
the job then Star Wars became a New Hope
and launched the most powerful franchise
in the Galaxy a lot of people involved
in the production were happy about it
but Guinness was not yes Star Wars made
him a lot of money but he famously
couldn't stand the film itself he
refused to open any mail related to the
film and even asked George Lucas to
limit future appearances of the Obi-Wan
Kenobi character because he hated the
dialogue
you don't need to see his identification
we don't need to see his
eyes these aren't the droids you're
looking for most famously Guinness once
told a young fan who claimed to have
seen Star Wars many times that he'd only
sign an autograph for him if he promised
to never watch the movie again
just about any list of the greatest
sci-fi films ever made has to include
Blade Runner Ridley Scott's 1982 classic
about a Cop tracking Rogue synthetic
humans across a futuristic Los Angeles
is still beloved today for its visuals
its performances and the many Mysteries
buried within its story structure Blade
Runner is also remembered for overcoming
so-so reviews extensive Financial
turmoil and development hurdles it's a
movie that persevered Against All Odds
to become a cult classic quite an
experience to live in fear isn't it
that's what it is to be a slave while
frequent re-edits re-releases sequels
and spin-offs have kept new audiences
finding the film and falling in love
star Harrison Ford apparently isn't one
of them in a 1999 interview with SFGate
Ford said that no matter which cut of
Blade Runner he watches he responds the
same way I didn't like the movie one way
or the other I played a detective who
did not have any detecting to do in
terms of how I related to the material I
found it very difficult there was stuff
that was going on that was really nuts
despite these struggles Ford eventually
did return to the role of Deckard for
Blade Runner 2049
sometimes actors dislike movies they
made because they didn't like the script
or they just did it for the money or
they were overwhelmed by the fame thrust
upon them then there's Crispin Glover
who has his own very specific reasons
for disliking Back to the Future
what are you doing I'm writing this down
this is good stuff yeah okay in a 2012
interview with the AV club looking back
on his career Glover went into a lot of
detail about why he didn't appear in
either of the film sequels as George
McFly it's complicated and it actually
helped set legal precedent but according
to Glover a lot of it started with his
own dislike of the film's ending when
Marty McFly goes back to 1985 and finds
that his parents are happy and his
father is a successful and Wealthy
sci-fi author for Glover that kind of
ending just sends the wrong message he
said I think there would be a better
message if instead of the Sun character
pumping his fist in the air or whatever
if instead the reward was that the
mother and father characters are in love
with each other and that there's the
potential that money comes in I think
equating their new riches with moral
success is a bad message for Glover the
riches as reward ending of the film only
further served corporate interests
director Robert zemeckis however did not
seem to agree Kate Winslet was already
an accomplished young actor by the time
Titanic came around but Jane James
Cameron's film about the sinking of the
legendary ocean liner made her into an
international Superstar though she's
since gone on to many other roles and
even won Oscars for her non-titanic work
Winslet will forever be known in the
eyes of many as the Love Struck robes
immortalized in memes and on basic cable
for years to come that said when the
time came for a Titanic 3D re-release
Winslet admitted that she actually
doesn't like watching the film very much
it's not Cameron's filmmaking though
it's her own performance she told the
telegraph every single scene unlike
really really you did it like that oh my
God even my American accent I can't
listen to it it's awful I have a hard
time watching any of my performances but
watching Titanic I was just like oh God
I want to do that again
I'll never like
Love Actually is one of those films that
did well when initially released but has
grown its Audience by Leaps and Bounds
in the years since the romantic comedy
Anthology about various londoners and
their relationships in the weeks leading
up to Christmas has become a holiday
staple for many continuing to draw new
fans through annual theatrical showings
and Christmas movie marathons that
doesn't mean everyone who worked on the
film has to like it however while he
acknowledges the film's impact and even
agreed to return for the Red Nose Day
reunion special in 2017 Andrew Lincoln
has admitted in interviews that he was
never too comfortable with his own place
in the film as Mark the lovesick man who
professes undying affection to his best
friend's wife he told Entertainment
Weekly in one of the most romantic
movies of all time I got to play the
only guy who doesn't get the girl the
story is set up like a prism looking at
all the different qualities of love mine
was unrequited so I got to be this weird
stalker guy
in 2007 Catherine Heigl was an
up-and-coming actor still working on
making the big leap from TV stardom to
movie Fame she got a major break in the
form of Judd Apatow's knocked up a
comedy about the Fallout from a
one-night stand pregnancy Knocked Up was
a major success both critically and
commercially helped make Seth Rogen into
a comedic star and further cemented
Apatow as one of the genre's guiding
lights for Heigl though she enjoyed
making the film it was also an
unpleasant story about an uptight woman
do not make fun of me okay I am hormonal
I am terrified and I am falling apart so
stop treating everything like it's a big
joke she told Manatee fair in 2016 it
was a little sexist it Paints the women
as shrews as humorless and uptight and
it Paints the men as lovable goofy
fun-loving guys it exaggerated the
characters and I had a hard time with it
on some days 98 of the time it was an
amazing experience but it was hard for
me to love the movie
Robert Pattinson was one of several
young actors who had overwhelming fame
thrust upon them seemingly overnight
with the original Twilight film The
Batman brought him back to franchise
work but Pattinson has proven himself to
be predominantly art house-minded he's
not just a pretty face he's a capable
actor based on Stephanie Meyer's
massively popular novels of the same
name the five Twilight films drew a
rabid fan base to patinson and while
he's well aware of what the movies did
for him in terms of status he was never
actually a fan of the movies themselves
in 2011 he admitted to Vanity Fair that
it was weird to be kind of representing
something you don't particularly like
you better hold on tight spider monkey
asked in the movie phone interview if
he'd go see a Twilight film if he wasn't
in them he responded I would just
mindlessly hate it in the years since
however he seems to have warmed to the
films he told USA Today in 2019 now the
intensity has died down and it's just
very warm memories
Daniel Radcliffe's life changed forever
when he was cast as the title character
in the Harry Potter series of films
based on JK Rowling's Mega bestseller
series of books Radcliffe played Potter
in eight different films across an
entire decade of his life quite
literally growing up on the big screen
the actor has fond memories of his time
as the boy Wizard and always seems happy
to share memories of making the Potter
films but there was little doubt however
which film is his least favorite to
watch in 2014 he told the Daily Mail
it's hard to watch a film like Harry
Potter and the half-blit prince because
I'm just not very good at it I hate it
my acting is very one note and I can see
I got complacent and what I was trying
to do just didn't come across the help
is considered by some to be among the
best period dramas of the 2010s and it
earned widespread Acclaim focusing on
the interpersonal relationships between
black women working for white people in
Jackson Mississippi in 1963 at the
height of the Civil Rights Movement it
starred Viola Davis in an academy
award-nominated lead role today it may
be remembered as one of her most
celebrated roles but nevertheless she's
unhappy with the film and says she was
reluctant to take the part she told the
New York Times in 2018 I just felt that
at the end of the day that it wasn't the
voices of the maids that were heard I
know that if you do a movie where the
whole premise is I want to know what it
feels like to work for white people and
to bring up children in 1963 I want to
hear how you really feel about it I
never heard that in the course of the
movie Once I told the truth about that
I felt free it's likely few people would
know who Megan Fox was had she not
starred in Michael Bay's Transformers in
2007 the film introduced the
Transformers to a new generation and it
introduced box to the world why doesn't
my little pony just hop in the backseat
oh oh God I can't even tell you how much
I'm not your little bunny in the film
Fox plays the love interest of Shia
LaBeouf who gets caught up in the
Earthbound Adventures of Optimus Prime
and crew when they show up on their
doorstep since Transformers and its
sequel brought Fox a great deal of Fame
you'd think it would be at the top of
her list of favorite projects that is
not the case Fox was let go from the
production of the third Transformers
movie primarily due to a falling out
with Bay she told Wonderland in 2009
that bay was a nightmare to work with
saying he's like Napoleon he wants to be
like Hitler on his sets and he is so
he's a nightmare to work for
following something of a public Feud box
and Bay reconciled even working together
in the rebooted Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles films looking back on
Transformers and its sequel boxes said
she hates her rapping she told
Entertainment Weekly in 2009 people are
well aware that this is not a movie
about acting once you realize that it
becomes almost fun because you can be in
the moment and go all right I know that
when he calls action I'm either going to
be running or Screaming or both Ryan
Reynolds has starred in several
high-profile superhero movies but he
only truly regrets one Green Lantern
intended to launch a franchise of DC
Comics films Reynolds was at the center
of it all and anticipation was high
while the film was in production cast is
Hal Jordan the cocky test pilot who
stumbles upon an alien that bestows upon
him a Green Lantern power ring the film
had all the right names and story beats
of the comics but all the anticipation
landed with a thud collapsing in a
brightly lit CGI mess that didn't even
include a real suit the movie did so
poorly at the box office that it ended
DC's plans at the time in the years
since Reynolds has not been shy at
joining in on the joke the actor has
mocked his performance and various
aspects of the film on multiple
occasions and please don't make the
super suit green
or animated Reynolds doubled down in
Deadpool 2 by going back in time and
shooting himself in the head just as
he's about to accept the role of Hal
Jordan he's gone on talk shows appeared
in commercials and tweeted endlessly
about the full scope of Green Lantern's
awesomeness Reynolds told Entertainment
Weekly in 2016 it also fell victim to
the process in Hollywood which is like
poster first released date second script
last
Greece was a massive hit that
turbocharged the careers of Olivia
Newton-John John John Travolta and
others the film sequel was an often
forgettable pile of Celluloid except for
the fact that it gave the world one
Michelle Pfeiffer marking her largest
role to date at the time Greece 2
Revisited Rydal High School some two
years after the previous film this time
depicting British student Michael and
the object of his affections Stephanie
the leader of a girls gang that only
allows its members to date greasers for
freezes Greece 2 gave Pfeiffer a chance
to show her stuff singing and dancing
and taking a big leap towards becoming a
household name but it is also regarded
by some to be among the worst musicals
of all time she told hollywood.com in
2014 I hated that film with the
Vengeance and could not believe how bad
it is at the time I was young and didn't
know better
Pfeiffer also didn't think she'd get the
part calling her Casting a total fluke
High School Musical was a massive
success and it launched the career of
multiple Stars including Zac Efron Not
only was the film a hit but it also
spawned two sequels and Efron starred in
both of them playing Troy Bolton to
widespread popularity Ephron was a
teenage heartthrob who could sing dance
and look good doing it whoa time out on
that one after he put those films in his
rear view mirror Ephron got to work
playing more diverse roles while Musical
made him a star the way Ephron sees it
his most awkward stage in life was also
immortalized for generations of teens he
discussed how the role made him feel in
a 2021 interview with Men's Journal and
said I stepped back and look at myself
and I still want to kick that guy's ass
sometimes he's done some kind of cool
things with some cool people but I mean
he's still just that kid from High
School Musical by this point Ephron has
done a pretty good job leading Troy
Bolton in his past and he's also become
a documentarian he hosts a travel show
called Down to Earth with Zac Efron
which sees him traveling the globe in
search of Healthy Lifestyles
Bob Hoskins was an exceptional actor
lending power and presence to numerous
iconic roles but there's one iconic role
that didn't work out so well in fact
it's sometimes cited among the worst
movies ever made it was also the first
video game adaptation ever put to film
long before Chris Pratt ever said it's a
meme Hoskins took on the role of Mario
Mario in Super Mario Brothers in 1993.
his first and last name being the same
in the film was the first of many
mistakes made in its production with the
possible exception of the costumes for
Mario and Luigi little about the movie
relates to the source material alias but
we gotta do
it whoa cool fans aren't the only people
who hated Super Mario Brothers Hoskins
absolutely loathed the film and he never
kept that disdain to himself he told the
guardian in 2007. the worst thing I ever
did Super Mario Brothers it was a
nightmare the whole experience was a
nightmare it had a husband and wife teen
directing whose arrogance had been
mistaken for talent after so many weeks
their own agent told them to get off the
set dismissing them as idiots he cited
the project as his biggest regret
Matt Damon launched to super stardom
with Goodwill Hunting it brought his
career to new heights and it helped him
land his most iconic role Jason Bourne
Damon first played Bourne in The Bourne
Identity and has since appeared in three
sequels while the movies did
exceptionally well and solidified his
place as a Hollywood a-lister Damon
isn't a huge fan of the third film The
born ultimatum in an interview with GQ
he expressed his disappointment with the
script which he credited to Tony
Gilroy's deal to write a single Draft
take no notes or rewrites and receive
quote an exorbitant amount of money you
cannot run what you did Jason
you made yourself and know who you are
despite pointing out the script is the
reason for the film's lackluster
performance Damon doesn't hold Gilroy
accountable he explained I don't blame
Tony for taking a boatload of money and
handing in what he handed in it's just
that it was unreadable this is a career
Ender I mean I could put this thing up
on eBay and it would be game over for
that dude it's terrible it's really
embarrassing ultimately the shooting
script was rushed into production due to
a set release date
Circa the late OTS Sam Worthington had
become Hollywood's hottest flavor
Landing high-profile gigs headlining
Avatar a Terminator Sequel and a Clash
of the Titans remake tell him tell him
what your journey does not end well
Fate has spoken of course Avatar became
a once in a generation hit but
worthington's other two projects didn't
quite work out as well Titans which put
him alongside the likes of Liam Neeson
Ray fines Gemma Arterton Mass Mickelson
and other celebrated actors did fare to
middling business ultimately failing to
woo critics or audiences the film
eventually got a sequel with 2012's
Wrath of the Titans but Worthington
isn't a fan of his acting in Clash he
apologized to fans in a 2010 interview
with movie phone admitting I think the
first one we kind of let down some
people I think I can act better to be
honest just take all the notes from the
people that I've been reading about on
the net and give them a movie they want
When Brad Pitt was cast opposite Tom
Cruise and Anne Rice's eagerly
anticipated Interview with the Vampire
adaptation many saw it as a passing of
the torch here was Hollywood's hottest
young actor matched with its biggest
star in this darkest of tales who would
shine brightest in the eyes of some Noah
the movie made money but according to
Pitt it was a nightmare to shoot in a
2011 interview with Entertainment Weekly
Pitt explained how miserable he was
shooting for six months in the dark on
top of that he felt his character wasn't
as fully realized as he should have been
when asked if he knew what the role
would be going in Pitt replied no I
didn't there was no script I knew the
book and in the book you have this guy
asking who am I which was probably
applicable to me at that time I thought
you could have it all
shut up Luigi explaining that he got the
script two weeks before shooting Pitt
even tried to get out of his contract he
called producer David Geffen a good
friend of his and asked what it would
cost to break the contract when Gavin's
answer was in the neighborhood of 40
million dollars Pitt decided to take his
vitriol and like any good vampire just
suck it up
2015's Terminator Genesis cast Emilia
Clarke as a quasi-new Linda Hamilton in
the same character of Sarah Connor the
film aimed to reboot the franchise once
again and had it been successful Clark
would have had a cinematic vehicle for
years
come with me if you want to live
unfortunately the movie was deemed a
disappointment even if it did gross more
than 440 million dollars at the
worldwide box office because it
underperformed the planned sequel was
scrapped Clark spoke with Vanity Fair in
2018 about her experience as filming
Genesis noting that she'd seen the
film's director Alan Taylor get eaten
and chewed up on Terminator he was not
the director I remembered he didn't have
a good time no one had a good time on
top of that Clark expressed relief that
she wouldn't have to make any more
Terminator films according to the actor
crew on the neighboring production of
2015's Fantastic Four reboot another
infamously troubled shoot were spotted
wearing jackets that red at least were
not on Terminator in 2016 Clark was
asked about whether she'd ever returned
to the Terminator franchise she replied
no can I say that it's okay no uh-uh if
you've ever wondered what the worst
Batman movie was just head into your
local comic book store conduct a poll
and you'll inevitably hear a consensus
surrounding Joel Schumacher's last film
in the franchise if you happen to pass
by the one time Dark Knight himself
George Clooney you could ask him and
he'd likely agree when Clooney took the
role following Val Kilmer and
Schumacher's Batman Forever he was an On
The Rise TV star navigating a tricky
transition to films at the time it was
the biggest thing he had ever done and
while he recalls it is the role that
helped him secure Financial Freedom he
nevertheless regrets it more than he
does being in Return of the Killer
Tomatoes Clooney's Batman had nipples on
the bat suit a bad credit card and
dialogue corny enough to make Adam West
Grinch let's
get some ice
Clooney is no fan of the movie and has
apologized to the fans several times
during an appearance on the grand Norton
Show in 2016 he remembered the
experience as a disaster I always
apologize for that money went on to say
that he thought he'd destroyed the
franchise you know I thought at the time
this was going to be a very good career
move
um it wasn't long before donning the
Dark Knights cowl for the dceu Ben
Affleck was playing a different
superhero for Marvel his first foray
into costume crime fighting however
didn't receive any Encore performances
Affleck played Matt Murdock AKA
Daredevil in the 2003 movie A notorious
dud at the time while the film featured
notable Easter eggs for fans who had
long hoped to see their Hero on the
Silver Screen it deviated from The
Source enough to provoke others
Affleck's performance isn't terrible but
the movie features some bad acting
crummy dialogue and several scenes that
deserve to reside in the bottom of the
discount bin at your local 99 Cent Store
2015 Aflac admitted to Entertainment
Weekly that the film was a misfire
saying Daredevil didn't work at all that
was before people realized you can make
these movies and make them well there
was a cynical sense of put a red leather
outfit on a guy have him run around hunt
some bad guys and cash the check